hello readers today we're talking about
how the delivery of the speech affects
the impact of the words so what do I
mean by that it's all the ways that how
a person says something affects what
they mean words on a page may have a
certain definition but we humans use all
sorts of different ways to show what we
really mean we can say something quietly
or really loudly to emphasize a point we
can emphasize some words but not others
we can pause to create dramatic tension
we know that how something is said is
important because when we don't have
that information sometimes it's hard to
know what another person is really
saying say that you forgot about your
friend Eli's birthday party so you text
them hey sorry I missed your party
seriously for me this is one of the most
anxiety inducing situations that I
encounter on a regular basis
what does Eli actually mean here it's
fine or it's fine or it's fine is it
fine or isn't it
yeah I don't know Eli's tone and body
language which we can't see in just a
text message add in important elements
of meaning we can apply that knowledge
to how we speak and how we assess the
speech of others good public speakers
use a range of techniques to convey
their message to their audience which
goes beyond just the words that they say
they become actors who are telling us a
story on stage not just with their lines
but with their physical presence so
let's talk about some of these
techniques and then we'll watch a little
bit of a speech so you can spot some
examples
first there's vocal variety this means
using different speaking speeds and
changing between soft and loud speaking
volumes when people don't do this we say
that they're speaking in a monotone you
know bueller bueller vocal variation
adds excitement and emphasis to speech
then there's language here I mean the
choice of words and the rhetorical
devices the speaker uses to appeal to
their audience and make the audience
agree with their points so for example
if you're at a business convention you
would expect a speaker to use pretty
formal language like good evening my
esteemed colleagues tonight I want to
discuss the importance of market
research in connecting with our customer
base you wouldn't expect the speaker to
say Bern tootin I'm a hankerin to eat
environment tonight let's go - some gold
but if you were at a gold miner
convention maybe that's exactly what you
would expect to hear language also
includes the rhetorical devices that
help to structure an argument for
example repetition repeating the same
word or phrase can help hammer at home
or make the speaker's point feel more
urgent in Martin Luther King Junior's I
have a dream speech
he starts eight sentences in a row with
the phrase I have a dream so these two
points cover how a speaker talks but
there are also physical aspects to
giving a speech gestures and eye contact
visual aids and the use of the stage
area itself the speaker can pace back
and forth to show they're feeling
agitated or throw their shoulders back
to show they're feeling proud they can
use their hands to emphasize what
they're saying speakers can use props if
they want to a chart or image or an
object and just like actors can have
performances that are great and
performances that are only so-so
speakers can use all of these techniques
to great effect or they can miss the
mark by seeming phony or uncomfortable
so let's take a look at a speech and its
delivery to see if we can spot any of
these techniques and what messages they
convey this is a speech from 1988 by the
then governor of Texas and Richards at
the Democratic National Convention I'll
fast forward to the good parts those
were real people with real problems and
they had real dreams about getting out
of the depression I can remember summer
nights when we had put down what we call
the Baptist palette and we listened to
the grown-ups talk I can still hear the
sound of the Domino's clicking on the
marble slab my daddy had found for a
tabletop did you see what she did there
what's her language telling us about who
she is what did she do with her hands
there when she talked about the dominoes
she's telling us she's not fancy she's
from an ordinary background and she
helps us visualize the scene by wiggling
her fingers like she's putting down
dominoes from a young mother in Marina
Texas and I want to read part of it to
you okay how about that what did you
think about her opening up that letter
is that actually the letter she received
from the young mother probably not I
think I can see the text on it and it's
really big so she's probably reading
from a typed copy it's folded in thirds
though like a letter that came in an
envelope it gives you the impression
that this is a real letter something she
got in the mail and she's telling you
the plain truth from it this is a visual
aid okay let's skip the middle of the
letter and see how governor Richards
delivers the end of it and we plot along
trying to make it better for ourselves
and our children and our parents we
aren't vocal anymore I think maybe we're
too tired I believe that people like us
are forgotten in America what did you
notice about how governor Richards
delivered those last two sentences I
think maybe we're too tired
she sounds tired and she pauses between
the words I believe that people like us
are forgotten in America all of those
pauses give weight and emphasis to the
experience of the young mother this is
vocal variety okay this is the last one
we'll talk about they've told farmers
that they were selfish that they would
drive up food prices if they asked the
government to intervene on behalf of the
family farm and we launched farms go on
the auction block while we bought food
from foreign countries well that's wrong
they told working mothers it's all their
fault that families are falling apart
because they had to go to work to keep
their kids and jeans and tennis shoes in
college and they're wrong
they told American labor they were
trying to ruin free enterprise by asking
for 60 days notice of plant closings
what did you hear repeated several times
in this section that's wrong this is a
rhetorical device what does it make you
feel about the points governor Richards
was making here it kind of feels like
they're piling on each other right she's
adding more and more evidence to her
case so the next time you watch a speech
keep these techniques in mind they'll
help you see how a compelling speaker
can transform the text of the speech
with vocal and physical effects